for very long period of time starting in
the 1960s and then into the 1970s
computers were seen as a way information
technology in general is seen as a way
of making government bureaucracy more
efficient and effective and so the drive
was always a productivity efficiency
doing more with less maybe in the 1990s
or so we had another dimension coming
into this picture and that is to be more
consumer friendly or citizen friendly in
the services that the government
provides but these are just two very
specific ways of looking at how
government interact with society because
it looks at the citizens as consumers as
transactional partners with the
government you go for efficiency to
lower the cost or you go for the
consumer friendliness or transactional
partner friendliness in order to provide
some service quality
I believe that electronic government or
information technology and government
must go much further than that and we as
a society have a right to know better
what the government is doing to engage
with the government and to have a
government in place that is willing and
able to use the technological tools
available to engage US citizens that's
currently not happening or not happening
at a sufficiently high level we are
still in this old-fashioned mode of
thinking about transactions efficiency
and user friendliness
the US government lags behind in
electronic government quite a bit
largely because whenever you need to
create an electronic government
transaction software and you need to
involve a number of different government
stakeholders and they despise each other
usually and they hate when the other
side has access to their information and
data data silos and information silos in
government are one way of defining power
and influence and so obliterating those
silos really reduces the power of
individual departments and agencies and
that's why they are not keen on doing
that and let me give you up what I
thought a wonderful example if I may
there was a website on moving called
moving and it helped people who were
moving house to do the change of address
form to move the electricity and the gas
and the utilities over the telephone to
also hire perhaps a moving van and so
forth it was a one-stop shop for all of
this and it was a public-private
partnership that made this all possible
and it was a huge success people really
love this this website government
agencies realized that and they thought
gosh this means there's real traffic to
be generated and immediately what they
did was to leave that umbrella that
one-stop shop and to create their own
little shops in order to drive traffic
to their own little shops of course the
sum was really more the the the sum was
more than just the parts put together
and once you take these parts apart and
everybody has this little shop the
consumers really are frustrated again
and don't want to go to fifteen or
sixteen different websites in order to
change their addresses the problem
therefore is that when you break down
the side
as you create value when you reset the
silos you destroy value that's something
that government agencies theoretically
understand but have practical
difficulties realizing and putting in
place but I am really more interested in
another aspect I am interested in the
way by which government in the United
States has now decided to make public a
lot of the information that it collects
my colleague and friend Beth Novak and
others have really pushed this very hard
in the Obama administration and I think
that's exactly right
what we need is more information that
the government collects not personal
information but general information to
be shared with the public at large with
NGOs with the society at large so that
they can then look at that data and
really see what is happening in our
society we now have the software tools
to do that we now have the interest in
the public to do that and that's why we
need to move ahead and make more and
more of that government information
freely available
there's a huge difference if you look at
the website that the Obama
administration set up to be able to
trace the money of the simulus package
going into the economy and you can see
to which communities which counties to
what companies and institutions
organizations the money goes how much
has been dispensed what was the impact
on employment and so forth this data is
fabulously well designed and presented
through a geographic interface and it's
it is simply superb very very different
from the previous administration in fact
the outgoing clinton-gore administration
put in place for example a website with
the Environmental Protection Agency
where the Environmental Protection
Agency made accessible a self reporting
inventory of toxic waste and linked it
to a geographic information system so
that people could actually look at their
neighborhood and see whether there were
any toxic waste repositories in their
neighborhood
when that went online a lot of people
started pressuring the the companies in
their neighborhood that had toxic waste
to clean up and to get their act
together because land value would adjust
and so there was almost a wonderful
market force as well as the democratic
force behind it of course the George W
Bush administration after 9/11 took the
website down ostensibly because of the
security risk terrorists could access
the toxic waste inventory and find out
where the toxic waste was in this
country I am not so sure the security
risk really was that high I think a lot
of people in the I suspect a lot of
people in the Bush administration
connected to some of the toxic waste
errs we're quite happy to put that
database offline
first of all if we permit people to have
access to government information we
don't necessarily become more vulnerable
the cybersecurity task is mostly one
focused on keeping the infrastructure up
and running and we are very vulnerable
there they're very vulnerable not just
on the Internet information
infrastructure but on the energy and
electricity infrastructure as well and
we are well knurl because for many years
even decades we have increased the
efficiency of the infrastructure but
limited the investment in redundancy and
robustness of the infrastructure and
that makes all these infrastructures
prime targets for hackers and terrorists
around the world whether they are
organized by a nation-state or whether
they are non combatant terrorists of
al-qaeda's elector or anything else I
think we need to spend more money on
that I think we need to spend more money
on securing the infrastructure on
knowing what the other side is doing the
federal government does not have yet its
act together on cyber security that's
still a big problem it will require all
the major stakeholders to come together
it will require some legislative change
as well and it will require a different
mindset of the people the the missiles
of tomorrow are not going to come
through the sky they are coming through
the fiber-optic networks